foreign
[Music]
coming up what is a warm Bank well I've
been to visit one to find out
[Music]
and why are thousands of girls in Iran
been taken to the streets to protest
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello all that to come and more there's
a new report out about the state of our
Wildlife so Braden that's Jackson behind
us now he has invented a game about the
world's animals hi Jackson hi we'll
speak to you later
but first not all this week's stories
have been true or have they it's time
for fake news or fact
you know what these are right hello
how can I help you well we won't say
their name in case they go off in your
house the Posh name for them is
artificial intelligence or AI
well new Cambridge University Research
says artificial intelligence is making
us young people less intelligent how
dare they I know right apparently we're
relying on them too much and the answers
aren't always right or detailed enough
so do you think that's fake news or fact
you know what can I ask a lot no Brayden
we'll tell you later
[Music]
so Braden have you heard of something
called a warm bank I have heard of one
but I'm not quite sure what it actually
is well it's a very new idea so I don't
think many people know about it the
money our parents pay for heating is
higher than it's ever been before the
main reason has been the war in Ukraine
governments didn't want to buy gas and
oil from Russia anymore to cause
problems for the President Vladimir
Putin
but because there's less fuel available
the bills our parents pay have gone up
and even though the government are going
to help them it's still way more
expensive than last year
if your family are worried about paying
the bills one way you could save on
heating is talking to a trusted adult
and see if you could visit a wall Bank
[Music]
sometime now we've had food banks where
people who don't have enough money for
food are given vouchers to make sure
they get something to eat
but a warm bank is a bit different
they're for anyone so I thought I'd try
one out
I'm here with the film crew but if you
want to come to one make sure you talk
to a trusted adult first hi there I'm
good how are you
so far so good it's always a bit weird
walking into a place you've never been
before but luckily attia made me feel
really welcome they said I can stay here
as long as I want so when I put my phone
on charge there's lots of things to do
while you're here
you can get a book help yourself to a
hot drink grab a biscuit
play a game just hang out
it's nothing like a bank at all Steve
who has opened this one thinks warm
Banks need another name do you like it
yeah I love it here it has the feeling
of kind of like a homey and a very
chillaxed and friendly Library we wanted
to create exactly what you've said it
like a homey feel warm in every way but
we decided not to call them warm Banks
or warm spaces because we want people to
be able to save cash anyone can come in
and that's why it's not a warm Bank
foreign
Bank the living room makes sense to me
there'll be all sorts of different names
living room warm Bank warm space but
they'll all do the same thing a good way
to find out about one near you is to ask
at school they might even be running one
and it looks like they're going to be
really popular
what do you like the most about it I got
to play with my friends a bit more often
and I get to play football
I like the beads and you get to do
whatever you want in the playground area
I like do the drawing there I play
Monopoly
some children that come here they're
from other schools around the area they
love this community that's why they come
here
the name warm bank would suggest that
like you need to be warm because you
can't afford to be warm but it's really
not about that
it's a really nice Community here it's
safe and it's comfortable
living room warm Bank whatever it's
called it's good to know that there'll
be a safe and warm place to hang out
this winter
when you see a cricket do you think oh
lunch
how about now or would this be too much
on your plate ah yeah me too crickets
are certainly not a meat-free
alternative but it's sustainable and
they've always been a delicacy in
Thailand apparently though they're a bit
country so to make them easier to
swallow a fast food chain are using them
to make the boat burger oh
don't try this at home though with or
without ketchup eating random insects is
not a good idea
[Music]
what you up to Braden I'm just looking
at some of the other stories that's
going on in the world and I tell you
what there's a lot going on yeah I've
been following school girls in Iran
who've been protesting it's a very
strict regime they have in their country
so it's unusual to see anybody protest
really but especially girls our age yeah
I saw some of those look at this
yeah for a long time many girls and
women in Iran have been angry that they
haven't had a choice about whether to
wear head scarves or not they're forced
to
that's right and I found out that these
protest sites have happened because it
was reported a young woman dad while in
police custody
masahamini was arrested for not wearing
a headscarf properly
the police said that they were not
responsible for her death but people who
saw her injuries think the reports that
she had been beaten by the police are
true
sadly since then reports have been
emerging of other deaths
even some people who choose to wear
hijab don't think it's right you might
have heard of Malala yeah
she was given a Nobel Peace Prize after
her campaign for girls to be given the
chance to go to school
now she always wears a hijab but look
what she
whatever a woman chooses to wear she has
the right to decide for herself
though the girls have supporters all
around the world Iran has a special
police force who check what girls and
women are wearing and this strict regime
May mean the girls aren't allowed to
change the rules or even continue
protesting
women around the world have been showing
their support by saying that hair is
yours to do with as you please wear a
hijab don't wear a hijab cut your hair
grow your hair out they think it should
be your choice
A lot's been happening in Ukraine too
about a week ago the bridge between
Russia and Crimea was bombed
while Ukraine hasn't claimed
responsibility for the bridge attack it
does help their war effort because it
makes it harder for the Russians to get
supplies through to their army
and this is really embarrassing for
Russia's President Vladimir Putin as he
had built the bridge when he took
control of Crimea back in 2014.
so in return Putin ordered missile
attacks and we struck lots of places all
over Ukraine
Vladimir zelensky Ukraine's President
says that these missile attacks were a
little bit different because they were
targeted on where people lived including
the capital Kiev
world leaders you spoke on Tuesday said
that they would stand by Ukraine for as
long as it takes
[Music]
still to come numbers of mountain
gorillas are on the up but have you seen
a hedgehog recently we'll have the
latest on our planet's animals that is
really cute but first here's another one
of your reports where you tell us about
your world
foreign
Tobin and at the moment I'm walking
towards wales's Big Opera House the
Millennium Center
but why am I going inside here because
Opera is what I do during lockdown I
joined a zoom group one by the Welsh
national youth Opera now we're back to
normal
well as normal as Opera can be we meet
to learn rehearse and perform
I'm now in the rehearsal room being
Guided by my buddy Ellery
[Music]
Opera is a very important aspect of my
life because it um it frees me up and it
allows me to be it allows me to be a bit
quirky
if you met me on the street so how I
would talk to you then it's completely
different to the character I might play
on stage
everything in Opera is over the top it's
never it's never how I would talk to you
it's always like haha here I am someone
who knows all about that is Nikki Spence
he's a famous opera singer and he's come
to see what we do so turban is this a
archetypal warm-up here it's Welsh
national Opera it is
how essential is wiggling to opera
singers
I'm really interested to know how you
actually learn music because obviously
you can't read the music no in a normal
way that we would the boring way how do
you do it I'm registered blind I use
what we like to call Braille music so
braille's A system that blind people can
read so it's a system of race dots
[Music]
if they puncture the paper kind of thing
so you can feel them underneath the top
of the tippy top of your finger usually
your index finger so that gives you the
information so either words or in our
case music or music and words as we're
both singers brilliant so you will use
this really to take home and learn take
home and learn and reference so the
other way I learn is through a call and
response method
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
once I know the music I have to think
about how I will get around the stage
for our recent Opera the black spider
that we did in the youth Opera we put
tactile markings down on stage which
meant I could feel it underneath my feet
so when I was coming up to an edge I
knew that oh I have about another Pace
if I need to use the other Pace but like
I knew that any further I'm gonna go off
the edge
I also rely on other cast members to
guide me around the stage like Penelope
and Ewan they knew that if they needed
to grab me they could grab me and they
would move me sometimes like when we
were doing black spider when there's the
bit where you have to like kind of go
back into the crowd I know you've
definitely dragged me off stage at one
point
I gave them my permission to do that
because if they didn't have my
permission that wouldn't be very be very
nice I love watching you read the
Braille and that's kind of inspired me
in a way to think okay yeah I can do
that regardless of just anything that's
happened in my life I think Tobin is an
extremely impressive young man and the
fact that he wants to sing opera is good
news for us all
[Music]
cheers Tobin and if you do something a
little bit different then get in touch
with us via our fyr website you could
end up making a special report for us or
even sitting on the sofa like Jackson is
now
come on
hello Jackson how you doing good thanks
how are you I'm good thank you so what's
this this is the card game I invented
called SOS which stands to save our
species I like the name it's pretty
clever actually so how did it come about
so I was very lucky to go on holiday to
Costa Rica and visit a turtle
conservation place I got to learn
firsthand about animals that are at risk
of Extinction such as the hawksbill
turtle
and we've got pictures of that I mean
look at it it's massive yeah it was
amazing to see there are hardly any of
them left and they could be lost forever
so how do you play the game well the aim
of the game is to collect as many
species points as possible the more
endangered the species the higher the
points for example the Wild dog is worth
Four Points whereas the emperor penguin
is only worth one point so Jackson I
know you worked with World Wildlife Fund
on the game and I've heard they've got a
new report out yeah this is a health
check on the species and habitat in the
natural world so what's the headline on
average the population of all Global
Wildlife has decreased by 69 over the
last 50 years wow that's a lot take the
Oceanic whitetip shark for example it's
declined over 95 in the last 50 years
it's now on the Red List which means
it's critically endangered and it's not
just sharks on the decline is it no a
really important ecosystem that is at
threat is the coral reef sea Waters
continue to rise then all this amazing
marine life will be at risk but it's not
all bad news is it I've heard that
apparently some species are actually
growing yeah animals like the mountain
gorilla their numbers are actually
improving wow but you don't need to go
traveling to see wildlife here in
Britain if you haven't seen a hedgehog
in a long time that's probably a sign
that they're in decline in your area too
so how do we help animals in Decline
there's a feature in my game called The
Wildlife Corridor which is a card that
helps connect two habitats together and
that's the best way of protecting
Animals by protecting their habitat and
allowing them to move to New habitats
where they can survive one of the
reasons that they think hedgehogs are in
Decline is because they can't travel
from one place to another so a good idea
is to put a hole in your fence to make
sure your garden is a wildlife Corridor
for hedgehogs it's called a hedgehog
highway I think that's a really good
feature in the game when I'm sure the
Hedgehogs would be happy as well good
luck with your game thanks for coming in
today
right well there's just enough time to
figure out whether this week's story was
fake news or fact let's do it
[Music]
earlier on we told you about a report
that new research from Cambridge
University says AI artificial
intelligence is making us children less
intelligent because we're relying on
machines to give the answers rather than
work it out ourselves that's exactly it
well it's fake news it's fake because
there is no new research it was an
opinion given by someone from Cambridge
University
[Music]
I thought so there's nothing wrong with
my brain so you got that right then I'm
not prepared to answer that well that's
all from us and we thought with King
Charles's coronation set for the 6th of
May next year we'd leave you with a
corgi parade that took place in memory
of the queen at Buckingham Palace last
week
cute
[Music]